- We are back
and I can never say enough
about how grateful I am for my fans.
Y'all have inspired me.
They've been with me for like, 20 years.
Thank you so much.
I love meeting my fans, it's
the coolest experience ever,
especially to connect through music.
It's the coolest thing ever.
Most celebrities do.
But every once in a while,
we have an encounter so over the top,
it stays in our minds forever,
'cause you're like, "That happened."
And mine happened in a
bathroom of all places,
and I've interviewed many people
whose encounters were even more unusual,
which I was like, "Really?"
So, just take a look.
- I was in a commercial center,
I went to the toilet
and, yeah.
And then I was about to wee,
and then I just feel...
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I just feel someone staring at me
and I'm like.
And this guy, very happy,
and he just says,
"Are you the smiley guy from Ted Lasso?"
(everybody laughing)
Not even my character.
And I'm like, "Um, yeah?"
And he just goes like,
"Can I have picture?"
(everyone laughing)
- Can you give me a minute?
- Not right now.
- And I was like, "Um okay."
- You're like, shaking.
(laughing hysterically)
- Bathrooms are just
- [Kelly] You get trapped.
- You get trapped. Yeah.
And it's the worst for me,
'cause it's like, teenage
girls just follow me in
and it'll be like, a squad.
You know, if I go to Disneyland,
there's like, squads of
teenage girls that'll go
and they'll follow me in a bathroom
and then you come out
and you're bombarded
with seven random girls
just waiting there
and you're like, "Hello. Thank you."
- I please hope that you go,
"It all went well, thank you."
(everybody laughing)
And just keep walking. (laughing)
I know you had to have
had crazy passionate fans.
- Oh my gosh.
There's a list of just
crazy memories and--
- [Kelly] I can't imagine.
- --fan experiences from being in Brazil
and having thousands of
fans break into our hotel
and they had to call
the Brazilian National
Guard to get them out.
- What?
- These are very passionate fans.
I mean, it's why the books
and movies are so successful
is these fans, they don't give up.
They get what they want.
- I love the books and movies.
I would never break into your hotel room.
There are normal fans.
(both laughing)
There are people who
just appreciate the art.
(audience laughing)
- There was a time,
I think we were in Santiago, Chile,
and our fans were going crazy
and we got into the airport.
- What?
- They finally got us to the bus.
We have to walk through people,
over people, under people.
It was crazy,
but as we were driving away,
there was continuous banging,
and we were literally
miles from the airport,
and there were fans on top of
the bus banging on the bus.
We saw hands coming through the skylight
(everyone laughing)
and yeah.
The levels of love.
- Okay, I really like Meryl Streep
but I'm never gonna
climb on her car and...
(everyone laughing)
Everyone loves you.
You've done so many things
but do people like, out
of all your stuff, though,
do people, when you're
in a hardware store,
do they still do the (Tim Allen grunt)?
(Tim Allen grunting)
Yeah, yeah.
- It's "Grunt for me."
(Kelly laughing)
You know, like I'm one
of those little monkeys
that does this, you know?
- [Kelly] But they ask you?
- If they come and "Grunt
for me. Show the kids."
Or a cop pulls me over
'cause I have a very high-performance car
and it was making too much noise.
As soon as the window goes
down, he goes (grunting)
(everyone laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
I'm not gonna get...
- Hey, if it gets you out of the ticket,
I'd (grunting) all day long.
- It actually didn't.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- This is a true story.
This is about two years ago.
I was walking to work,
some girl stop me and was like,
"Hey, I just want to let you know,
you got me through a lot
of tough times in my life.
But watching your sketches
and watching your jokes,
it just got me through."
I go "Oh, appreciate it. That's awesome."
So I go, "I'm happy you're here."
And we talked for about 20 minutes,
and then she goes, "Can I have a picture?"
And I go "Yeah, of course."
So we took a picture, and we pose.
"Can I have one for Snapchat?"
And I go, "Yeah, of course."
So we take one for Snapchat.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And she goes, "Okay, well,
I'll talk to you later."
I go, "Hey, nice to meet you,"
She's walking away,
and as she's walking away, I swear,
she goes, "Oh my gosh, I can't
believe I met Jimmy Kimmel."
(everyone laughing)
20 minutes I was talking to this person.
- (laughing) That's so amazing.